I'm now pleased to introduce another
wonderful member of your class our
student speaker Brooke way she was
selected to speak today by a committee
of faculty staff and students
Brooke is graduating with a major in
physics and a minor in professional
writing Ann intends to pursue graduate
study in material science in the fall
Brooke when I pictured this day four
years ago this isn't what I thought it
would look like I thought I'd have it
all figured out by now I thought I'd
know exactly who I was where I was going
what direction my life is gonna take I
thought I'd be so ready to get out of
here and dive into a world where I'd
make big changes and be respected and
find success around every corner but
instead I'm scared I'm scared to leave
this Carnegie Mellon bubble where I live
with my best friends where I know every
shortcut around campus like the back of
my hand where the baristas at the
Starbucks on Forbes and Craig scribbled
out my name without even having to ask
maybe you're like me maybe some part of
you is scared to leave the group me
chats the annoying familiar beeping of
the crosswalk get more wood the tipsy
journeys down Bueller
two long lines at la prima the concerts
carnival the wine and cheese nights with
Red Solo cups I'm scared because for the
past four years my life has been
organized by post-it notes and lists and
I've diligently crossed off the problem
sets and essays one by one we all
complain about how busy we were but we
all know it was actually a competition
of who was the busiest it wasn't easy I
changed my mind
four times I cried when I got my first C
and I learned the limits of sleep
deprivation but we were always
surrounded by friends to talk to
professor's who inspired us and a
community that changed us the way a
writer revises a piece with love little
by little until we slowly evolved into
different people but now we're here now
we're gently being nudged out of the
safe and nurturing world where even the
weather was predictable always rain the
most frightening part about the future
is the uncertainty the worry that your
dreams could come crashing down on you
just as easily as they could be achieved
whether you're starting your first real
job or going to med school or grad
school or still trying to figure out
what you want the future may seem
obscured by fog but the best part about
uncertainty is that it's equivalent to
possibility I've sometimes found myself
lamenting over the things I should have
done I should have tried out for dance
or symposium instead of chickening out
before auditions I should have taken
more philosophy classes
I should have stayed on the Frisbee team
should have said I love you more often
should have gone out more a whore got
out less I learn how to use that
expensive and hipster DSLR camera I
bought instead of relying solely on my
iPhone and Instagram filters should have
said where did that keeper Issa then can
I have a touch ID please
but what am I saying this is just the
beginning it wasn't that long ago when
we went out to bars for the first time
and got our Viking hats from Peters pub
we've got our entire lives ahead of us
we've got all the time in the world to
do the things we want to do visit the
places we want to see become the people
we've always dreamed of becoming who did
you want to be when you first got here
when I first came to Carnegie Mellon I
want it to be an astrophysicist I wanted
to look up at the night sky and
understand how we came to be made of
Stardust on this little planet in this
infinite universe I've discovered a new
interest since then we all have but this
amazement this wonderment of the world
the sense of unbounded possibility is
something we must fiercely hold on to
throughout college there are plenty of
times when the workload was too much
when the stress felt overwhelming when I
wondered it was time to give up but the
thing about Carnegie Mellon is that
inspiration is everywhere whether it's
one of those nerdy moments when you
learn something in one class that clicks
with something from another class or the
pride you feel when you see your friends
on stage during Greek sing or a culture
night or the excitement of reading about
one of your professors researching the
news something always keeps the spark
going
pushing you to keep growing oftentimes
in ways you weren't even expecting as
Carnegie Mellon students we're sometimes
so determined and driven that when we
set goals for ourselves it's strange to
see them change or even fail I thought I
was gonna be a physicist but now I'm
becoming an engineer my boyfriend is
graduating as an engineer but now he
wants to be an entrepreneur
some of you were shy when you first got
here and then became organization
leaders and performers and mentors but
that's why we don't have just one school
color
we're plaid Carnegie Mellon taught us to
get out of the little box you might have
put ourselves in to explore the
possibilities to realize how many
different roles we have the intellect
and the talent to pursue in this world
this is how Carnegie Mellon has made me
stronger how it's made you stronger and
what we should all take with us when we
leave as we go through our lives let's
continue to keep our eyes wide and our
minds open because although there are
some of you who took a perfect path
that's not always the only path look at
the moon isn't it beautiful my dad asked
me during one of my uninspired slumps
yeah I sniffled wondering where he was
going with this but it's only ever a
full moon once a month he continued most
of the time it's just the Crescent or a
Half Moon it's almost never a full yet
it's always beautiful none of us are
perfect and few of us are sure of
exactly what we want yet we all break
sometimes but we've also all made it to
this day to the brink of the rest of our
lives and we're ready for it what we
learned enjoyed and discovered along
rollercoaster ride we call
carnegie-mellon is how true success
happiness and full potential are
achieved we might be going our separate
ways after we graduate but we'll never
forget the time we spend here together
growing together doing first together
becoming great people together let's
take the strength we've gained through
this transformation and tackle the
future in front of us I want to thank my
friends my family and my professors for
always believing in me thank you for the
late-night conversations for the
unwavering support for the life
philosophies thank you for being the
mirror that reflects a better version of
myself back at me and on behalf of all
my fellow classmates thank you to
everyone who has helped us become
Carnegie Mellon graduates when I
pictured this day four years ago this
isn't what I thought it would look like
I thought I'd have it all figured out by
now I thought I know exactly who I was
where I was going what direction my life
is gonna take I thought I'd be so ready
to get out of here and dive into a world
where I'd make big changes and be
respected and find success around every
corner but instead I'm even better off
sure I don't know exactly who I am yet
but I do know that I can be anyone you
can be anyone so class of 2015 I
challenge you to embrace the uncertainty
I challenge you to find passion to want
something to walk to the sky for it I
challenge you to let go of the fears
while holding on to each other let's
take the knowledge the strength and the
confidence that we've learned here
together
and let's go make this world ours thank
you